i do have christmas presents for you
guys that are related to the show if you
want what
do you mean yeah hold on one second let
me drop them off oh okay should we talk
while sam is getting these or our
engineer sam just alerted us that he had
presents for us by the way when this
airs it'll probably be mid to late
january yes they're from me matt i will
mail you yours
uh i got an ad around christmas time
from a store on etsy that i'd used
before and the email made me laugh so
hard it's it said do you have a
beautiful name have it engraved on an
ornament which made me laugh because it
implied i would have my own name
made on an ornament like a psychopath it
didn't say like do you does a loved one
have a beautiful name so it made me
laugh and then i thought of the most
beautiful name i could think of and i
had these made merry christmas guys hey
oh that's so nice catechi
oh
look at that that's beautiful i think
they're supposed to be baby's names nice
beautiful catechi well i haven't
mentioned this but we named our daughter
catechi
as you made her
cut a guy as god made this is so cool
it's really cool
thank you sam that's really pretty sorry
it's mid-january yeah i know i still i
have crinkling you know what there's no
there's really no reason why a christmas
gift
needs to be given at christmas armenian
christmas
yeah even armenian chris when is
armenian christmas it was january 6th
yeah oh is that just why are they just
being difficult it's the orthodox
christmas what do you mean are we just
being difficult just
how hard is it to move it to the 25th a
lot of people celebrate it on january
6th you can't say oh are you does an
entire culture celebrate on a different
day just to be difficult no i realize
that could come across as insensitive
yeah you think
um i just think how hard would it be to
just slide it it's a couple of days not
us we do it on the 26th why can't you
push it to january 6th because everyone
does it on the 25th yeah but just oh i'm
the irish the irish like to have it on
march 9th
and we the tree has to be upside down
and uh it has to be shooting guinness
out at the bottom of it
um
yeah well this is a good time to say
merry christmas you too uh for god's
sake it's what is it now it's late
january
uh no we're not uh you know i do i
worked so hard to get make this an
evergreen show to not have a christmas
trick excuse me would you say like a
christmas tree evergreen
god
i like these to be always fresh people
can hear them at any time why can't
people hear them and be like oh they
recorded this around christmas cause we
did why is that that's okay i want it to
constantly be a mystery i want my
movements and motions to be a mystery
come on i want people to never know
where i am i'm like saddam hussein i've
got doubles out there triples i want
people to never know what's conan up to
i don't like it when we're specific
about when we're recording or where
we're recording you're the most easily
recognizable person i know
like
11.